نساء فاتنه لكنهن قد يطيحن بعرش واحد من
اقوى رجال العالم في لحظات ترامب في مازق
مع قصصه الغراميه السابقه
نجمه مجله
تقول انها تلقت 150 الف دولار مقابل صمتها
عن علاقه غراميه
خرجت لتدعي انها تلقت 130 الف دولار
لاخفاء علاقه جنسيه بترامب فهل صحيح ان
ترامب كان زيرا نساء ولديه الكثير من
القصص هذا ما تحقق فيه المحكمه وما قد
يحدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي
لم افكر ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في امريكا ولم اعتقد ابدا انه يمكن ان
يحدث الجريمه الوحيده التي ارتكبتها هي
الدفاع بلا خوف عن امتنا من اولئك الذين
يسعون الى تدميرها
تجسست الديمقراطيون على حملته تذكر ذلك
لقد هاجموني بتهم من التحقيقات الاحتياليه
زوجه ترامب عارضه الازياء السابقه ميلانيا
لا يبدو انها سعيده بقصص زوجها مع النساء
وان كانت غير مثبته في المحكمه حتى اللحظه
غيرتها وربما اشياء اخرى دفعتها للاختفاء
عن الاضواء وعدم الظهور بجانب زوجها في
محنته الحاليه
وحدها البنت سر ابيها اذا ابنه ترامب
المدلله تواصل الدفاع عن والدها وتنفي عنه
عده تهم منها التحرش الجنسي يواجه ترامب
34 تهمه نفاها كلها في محكمه نيويورك منها
تهم فساد ومنها تهم احتيال ونساء قد يكون
كيدهن سببا في وضع اقوى رجال العالم خلف
القضبان